and you'll want to join us tomorrow
because the hero pilot and heroic crew
of Southwest Airlines flight 1380 it's
gonna be right here in studio 57 you
know what it is their first joint live
interview about to get out together they
helped save more than 100 passengers
after an engine explosion we'll hear
more about what happened inside the
cabin that's tomorrow right here on CBS
this morning this is the first time
they've all been together I've heard
parts of the story because I've talked
to Tammy Joe Schultz who's the pilot
really just an incredible group of
people yeah we've heard from the pilots
and the copilot but I am curious about
the flight attendants who really have
more interaction with the with the with
the passengers during the time like I
know I feel like I've been thinking of
questions ever since it happened so I
only have 212 for them tomorrow about
everything they went down including from
my kids who asked questions I hadn't
even thought of about just what you do
in a situation situation looking forward
to that they're a great group of people